♪ ♪
>> President Trump: ONE OF THE
IDEAS SUGGESTED AS THEY OPEN,
THEY PAY A PRORATED DOWN PAYMENT
FOR THE WALL WHICH I THINK
PEOPLE AGREE THAT YOU NEED, YOU
NEED THE WALL, IN FACT I SEE A
LOT OF DEMOCRATS, ALMOST ALL OF
THEM ARE BREAKING SAYING WALLS
ARE GOOD.
>> HOW WAS A WALL MORE IMPORTANT
THAN FAMILIES?
THIS SHUTDOWN IS NOT A GLITCH,
IT IS A CRISIS THAT THE
PRESIDENT CREATED IN THE
PRESIDENT ALONE CAN END.
>> John: JUDGE
ANDREW NAPOLITANO, MORGAN
ORTAGUS AND JONATHAN SWAN
REPORTED FOR AXIOS.
THE PRESIDENT ASKING FOR A
PRORATED DOWN PAYMENT IN A
CONTINUING RESOLUTION THAT WOULD
FUND GOVERNMENT FOR THREE WEEKS.
I DID THE MATH, 5.7 BILLION
DIVIDED BY 365 TIMES 21 --
$327 MILLION HE WANTS.
CAN HE GET THAT OUT OF THE
CONGRESS?
>> I CANNOT DO MATH IN MY HEAD
THE WAY YOU JUST DID.
>> I DID IT ON THE COMPUTER.
>> THIS HAS DEVOLVED INTO A
CAFETERIA FOOD FIGHT WITH THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS SAYING
"BUT HE STARTED IT" AND THAT'S
WHY PEOPLE ARE SO FRUSTRATED.
WHATEVER MORAL ARGUMENT THAT
NANCY PELOSI AND THE DEMOCRATS
FELT THEY HAD AROUND CHRISTMAS
OR EVEN TWO WEEKS AGO, FOR ME
THAT HAS EVAPORATED.
THERE IS NO POINT, WE HAVE THIS
MANY RESOLUTIONS COME TO THE
TABLE THAT YOU ARE NOT SEEING
DEMOCRATS NEGOTIATE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS STANDOFF IS HURTING REAL
PEOPLE.
THERE ARE REAL PEOPLE IN THE
NAVY RESERVE THAT I DRILL WITH,
THAT OUR FEDERAL AGENTS THAT
WORK AT THE U.N. IN NEW YORK,
THESE ARE FRIENDS OF MINE THAT
HAVE CHILDREN THAT ARE LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK BECAUSE
THEY MAY HAVE A WIFE OR HUSBAND
AT HOME -- I THINK IT'S TIME FOR
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE TO GET
OVER THEMSELVES AND GET A REAL
SOLUTION HERE.
THIS MORAL IMPERATIVE THE
DEMOCRATS THINK THEY HAVE, IT
HAS BEEN WASHED AWAY.
IT'S TIME TO COME TO THE TABLE.
>> John: IS IT TELLING THE
DEMOCRATIC MEASURE TO OPEN THE
GOVERNMENT WITH NO MONEY FOR THE
WALL GOT TWO MORE VOTES IN THE
SENATE THAN THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN
DID?
>> I WAS SURPRISED THE SIX
REPUBLICANS WENT FOR IT.
I WANT TO PICK UP WHAT MORGAN
WAS SAYING AND NOT ADDRESS THE
POLITICS AND MORALITY BUT JUST
ADDRESS THE CONSTITUTION.
ACCORDING TO CONGRESSMAN WILL
HURD, FORMER CIA AGENT AND A
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN THROUGH
WHOSE DISTRICT MOST OF THE WALL
WOULD PASS, THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THAT PROPERTY IS NOT OWNED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESIDENT CANNOT CONDEMN
PROPERTY ON HIS OWN, HE CAN ONLY
DO THAT WITH THE EXPRESS
AUTHORIZATION FROM CONGRESS.
HE SAID MOST OF MY CONSTITUENTS
ARE SAID NOT IN MY BACKYARD --
THAT MEANS LITIGATION OVER THE
VALUE OF EACH PARCEL OF
PROPERTY.
THE PRESIDENT CAN GET
7.000000000 TOMORROW, HE WON'T
BE ABLE TO SPEND IT FOR YEARS.
>> John: YOU HAVE TO BUILD IT
OUT OF THE RIO GRANDE
FLOODPLAIN, THESE MIGRANTS
COMING UP FROM HONDURAS WHO WANT
TO GET APPREHENDED WOULD HAVE TO
CROSS AMERICAN SOIL, IT WOULD BE
LIKE ONCE THERE ARE PROTECTED BY
DUE PROCESS.
FEDERAL WORKERS WILL MISS THEIR
SECOND PAY PERIOD AND FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE THIS REALLY IS GOING
TO BEGIN TO BITE.
HOW DO YOU READ POLITICAL
PRESSURE AND HOW IT'S GROWING,
WHO WAS AT PUTTING PRESSURE ON
CONGRESS OR THE PRESIDENT?
>> IT'S HARD TO SAY BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT IS SEEING THE
COAST GUARD NOT GETTING PAID AND
TRY TO HOTLINE A BILL TO PAY
THEM THROUGH THE SENATE THAT THE
MILITARY -- TRUMP SEES THAT AS
HIS CONSTITUENCY HE SAYS A LOT
OF THE WORKERS ARE DEMOCRATS SO
HE DOESN'T DISTINGUISH IN SOME
WAY ABOUT THAT.
DEMOCRATS, THESE ARE THEIR
CONSTITUENTS ESPECIALLY MEMBERS
FROM STATES WITH LOTS OF FEDERAL
WORKERS.
MARYLAND, VIRGINIA, THERE IS
PRESSURE ON BOTH SIDES.
THE LEADERSHIP IS SO DUG IN,
NANCY PELOSI HAS SAID WALLS ARE
IMMORAL SO FOR HER TO THEN GIVE
MONEY FOR SOMETHING CALLED A
WALL IS OFF THE TABLE.
STEEL SLATS OR WHATEVER.
>> John: SO IS TAKING DOWN A
MORAL WALL THAT ALREADY EXISTS
ALONG THE BORDER.
>> I WAS TALKING TO SOMEONE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY, DEMOCRATS
ARE SAYING MAYBE WE'LL GIVE YOU
5.7 BILLION FOR THINGS ALONG THE
BORDER BUT NOT BARRIERS OR
WALLS -- THAT'S NOT GOING TO CUT
IT.
THAT'S EVERYTHING EXCEPT FOR
WHAT TRUMP REALLY WANTS.
>> IF YOU'RE WATCHING THESE PAST
TWO WEEKS I THINK YOU WERE
RELATED.
ANY THOUGHT THAT YOU HAD THAT
THE DEMOCRATS MIGHT MODERATE AND
TRY TO BE RESPONSIBLE, IF THIS
IS THE BEHAVIOR WE'VE SEEN IN
LAST TWO WEEKS GOING INTO 2020,
THE PRESIDENT'S REELECTION
CAMPAIGN MUST FEEL GREAT.
>> John: THERE SEEMS TO BE A
DISCONNECT.
I WANT TO JUMP AHEAD AND REPLACE
SOMETHING THAT WILBUR ROSS SAID
THAT EVEN THIS PRESIDENT SAID HE
COULD HAVE SAID BETTER AND
WILBUR ROSS WALK THAT BACK.
>> THE BANKS AND CREDIT UNION
SHOULD BE MAKING CREDIT
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THESE ARE GOVERNMENT GUARANTEED
LOANS.
WE ARE PAINFULLY AWARE THAT
THERE ARE HARDSHIPS INFLICTED ON
THE INDIVIDUAL WORKERS.
ALL I WAS TRYING TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE AWARE THAT
THERE ARE POSSIBLE OTHER THINGS
THAT COULD HELP TO SOMEWHAT
MITIGATE THEIR PROBLEMS.
>> John: THE ADMINISTRATION IS
TRYING TO TAKE THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND TO SAY WE KNOW THE
WORKERS ARE HURTING BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT WE GET BORDER SECURITY
AND WILBUR ROSS SAYS I DON'T
KNOW WHY THEY CAN'T GET A LOAN.
>> I THINK HE CUT THE GROUND UP
FROM UNDER THE PRESIDENT.
HE CAN CALL UP HIS BANKER AND
GET A LOAN FOR ALMOST ANYTHING
THAT HE WANTS BUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WORKERS CANNOT DO
THAT.
IT'S ONE THING TO SAY YOU WORK
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, IT'S
BANKRUPT, WHAT DO YOU EXPECT
THERE'S TIMES WHEN THEY CAN'T
PAY THEIR BILLS -- IT'S ANOTHER
THING TO SAY WHAT'S WRONG WITH
YOU?
GO BORROW THE MONEY, NOBODY
ACCEPTS THAT IS A REASONABLE
RESPONSE.
>> John: THE PRESIDENT HAD HIS
HEELS DUG IN, HE SAID I'LL SEE
YOU ON THE 29TH, SHE WROTE HIM
BACK KNOW YOU WON'T AND THEN WE
HEARD THERE WAS GOING TO BE A
PLAN B.
LATE LAST NIGHT THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED NANCY PELOSI ASKED ME TO
GIVE THE STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS, SHE THEN CHANGED HER
MIND, THIS IS HER PREROGATIVE I
WILL DO THE ADDRESS WHEN THE
SHUTDOWN IS OVER, I'M NOT
LOOKING FOR AN ALTERNATIVE VENU
VENUE.
HE GOT THE POLITICAL CAPITAL OF
MAKING HER DISINVITED HIM BUT
THEN DOES HE LOSE BY SAYING
SHE'S RIGHT?
>> IT WAS OUT OF CHARACTER FOR
TRUMP.
IT WAS SURPRISING TO SEE HIM DO
THAT.
THERE'S SOME BACK STORY HERE,
THE TWO THINGS I'VE LEARNED IS
THERE ARE REAL LOGISTICAL ISSUES
BUT MORE THAN THAT I HEARD THIS
FROM PEOPLE WHO DISCUSSED THIS,
HE LIKES THE TRADITION.